[Music]
hello you're watching the press preview
it's the first look at monday's front
pages and in the next 20 minutes or so
we'll see what's making the headlines
with annabelle denham and zoe williams
chat to them in a moment first of all
let's check out those front pages for
you we're going to start with the metro
it highlights a paratrooper photographed
with a baby at kabul airport who
featured actually one of stuart ramsey's
reports here on sky news the headline
the metro have gone with i was just
doing my duty
the financial times leads on the
developing story in afghanistan
announcing that the prime minister is
set to hold crisis talks following the
u.s retreat and the mail pictures the
chaos of kabul's airport saying boris
johnson plans to plead with joe biden
their headline don't cut and run yet joe
the express leads with these same crisis
talks their front time running out for
trapped britons
well the telegraph reports downing
street hopes the g7 will focus on the
long-term outlook for afghanistan as
well as the current evacuation efforts
the front of the eye also looks at the
british response to the u.s withdrawal
from afghanistan with the headline rift
grows with u.s over afghan withdrawal
the guardian says boris johnson will
plea with joe biden to keep us troops on
the ground in afghanistan
well the times leads on the continuing
chaos in kabul citing growing fears of
an isis attack at the airport something
president biden mentioned earlier and
the star has good news for staycationers
with 12 days of hot weather forecast
including highs of 27 degrees
and i'm joined by annabelle denham and
zoe williams great to see you this
sunday evening thanks for being with us
um zoe why don't we start with the front
of the metro then uh that image there of
the paratrooper holding uh a little baby
uh filmed by our sky news crew
at kabul airport and it does some things
up really doesn't it especially the
incredible work uh that the paras are
doing out there um they've told stuart
ramsey our chief correspondent that it's
harder than what they've seen and
experienced on previous tours they've
been on in afghanistan and really we
we need to have a huge amount of respect
for them
quite and and i think um
the thing is there are a huge amount of
really harrowing stories coming out of
kabul um many of them
kind of lighting on these parents
desperate parents who are having to pass
their children over to strangers i mean
granted paratrooper strangers but
strangers just to get them out and it's
re and it really brings home
just the kind of lack of preparation
there's been for this moment you know
there's it's like
it's the the kind of time span between
trump's agreement
biden's acceptance of the agreement and
biden's strategy for withdrawal was so
long and yet there was
absolutely the things are happening
minute by minute that are not foreseen
in any of those plans and it does land
on the heads of these individual
paratroopers as you say who are doing
impossible work
trying to help people and not knowing
how long that help will continue and
what is left for the people left behind
yeah and uh the work
uh that they are doing they're really up
against the clock um aren't they
annabelle and a lot of talk today about
whether this deadline of august the 31st
can be extended just to give them more
time to get more people out i mean do
you see that being feasible we know that
the the g7 are going to meet virtually
on tuesday it's going to be discussed
can it happen
i mean i think that there's no option
but for it to happen that joe biden set
a deadline for the 31st of august to
begin with was quite clearly
unrealistic and i think that the u.s
president has accepted now that you know
the american strategy of no man left
behind is going to come first they are
going to have to evacuate u.s citizens
and bring them back to u.s soil and i
don't think they've really got much
choice but to do that but of course over
the course of this week we've heard
about the thousands of u.s citizens who
are still in kabul who are still in
afghanistan there's a huge amount of
work to be done so i think when it comes
to the sorts of discussions that our
leaders are going to have in the coming
days and weeks this this should be a
relatively straightforward one yeah
let's look at the front of the daily
mail then
uh shall we zoe uh don't cut and run yet
joe is their headline amid fears there
may only be two days left to get
refugees out of afghanistan the pm uh
pleads with biden there have been talk
that uh the uk operation may finish uh
in the next couple of days or so but
let's hope that it can continue but what
is particularly worrying uh is that
president biden tonight saying when he
addressed the u.s public that there is a
real security threat now at the airport
so not only have you got to worry about
people being crushed running out of food
and water trying to get on the planes
but also you got to worry about isis
well i mean that was inevitable though
wasn't it as soon as you as soon as you
broke uh
agreement with the taliban on this kind
of rather flimsy basis that they would
themselves try and stamp out terrorism
when they have the same agenda in many
ways as al qaeda and isis that followed
of course they weren't going to be any
kind of um barrier between the
government of afghanistan and the
terrorist elements within it so that's
not at all surprising and furthermore it
shouldn't come as a surprise to either
biden or johnson because it was said by
many of their civil servants beforehand
for many months beforehand um
the the point is that i mean i feel that
the british media is sort of throwing
this
is sort of framing this as though the
british are begging the americans to
think harder and be more considered
whereas i think
from the international community's
perspective both the british and the
americans should have thought harder and
been more considered before we got to
this date
if americans lose control by leaving
kabul airport
then there will not be an obvious safe
route out for the people left there
whether they're british citizens u.s
citizens or indeed afghan citizens who
have helped the allied forces to the
extent that they would be persecuted
after the withdrawal so
it doesn't strike me as at all plausible
for biden to keep on with the deadline
as it stands
um the problem is as you said in your
bulletin that the taliban representative
has said that there'll be problems from
their end if the deadline isn't
respected
what those problems would look like
considering they've already rescinded on
four out of five of the terms agreed
with trump
is yet to be seen um but it's certainly
going to get worse before it gets better
yeah it's a good point and let's put
that to annabelle because we're seeing
these bizarre
bizarre images of of us forces working
with the taliban outside the airport i
mean images that we would never have
thought were were possible but it's
clearly a a fragile truce at the moment
and it can't last forever
no exactly it's quite interesting that
on the cover of one newspaper you've got
this unholy alliance between uh uk us
troops and the taliban and on the others
you've got stories about a rift between
or developing rift between uh the uk and
the us and the future of the special
relationship really being thrown into
peril i mean when it comes to sort of
perhaps the longer term prospects and i
i'd be very surprised if we do see
terrorist activity in the coming days
because i think it simply isn't in the
taliban's interest it isn't in the
interest of a lot of people um who would
become belligerent potential terrorists
in afghanistan at the moment i think
what they need uh is for things to
remain as peaceful as possible at least
in the very short term until there's a
full withdrawal of troops and after then
they'll there'll be a decision for
taliban leaders to make which is are
they going to impose sharia law are they
going to go back to uh the era of
pre-2001 are they going to harbour
terrorists and the like or are they
actually going to try and make
themselves a serious player on the world
stage are they going to forge uh
stronger relationships with russia and
china for instance so it yeah it's very
interesting but nonetheless unsettling
times ahead and i agree with zoe that
things are going to get worse before
they get better unfortunately yeah and
that leads us very nicely onto the front
of the financial times zoe crisis talks
as russia and china are drawn into the
afghan aftermath boris johnson um
obviously hosting these talks is uh uh
uh uh as we've been saying on tuesday
but of course china and russia are gonna
be vital aren't they uh as we as we look
to the future
well this was something that came up a
lot in the emergency parliamentary
debate last wednesday that actually the
uk as the head as the lead on the g7
this year and as such a key player in
nato should have been building these
international bridges and strategies for
months in advance and the fact that
they're starting now
as
apparently in response to that emergency
parliamentary debate
is just chilling you know it really
suggests government
done on a shoestring by the seat of his
pants so
it's it's difficult to see the uk taking
the same leadership role as it would
have done if it had assumed that role in
a timely and
um reputable manner nevertheless you're
completely right there there is no there
is no unilateral response to the
situation in afghanistan unless it's a
forever war waged by the uk or the us
against the nation you know there is
it has to be bilateral it has to be
international in order for anything
constructive to take place um
it's it's quite there's a question mark
over
what russia's role will be in building
that constructive response given how um
given how invested it's been of late in
creating instability abroad rather than
solving it yeah and uh just before we go
to the break um annabelle it'll be
interesting to get your thoughts on joe
biden obviously
speaking once again to the u.s public
this evening but polls are showing that
his approval ratings are sliding to new
lows do you think this is all meant that
the honeymoon with the american people
is over
uh yes i mean absolutely i think
what's really interesting is if you
looked at polling from april this year
around 69 of americans were in favor of
withdrawing us troops from afghanistan
but that's changed drastically um you
know with the hasty uh retreat uh that
we've seen in the recent uh weeks and
i think that americans
are taking a more isolationist stanch of
course they are and joe biden is driving
that forward with america first and i
think that
even though that there is that sort of
overriding kind of emotion that they
have over in the us at the moment in the
public um actually what they hate more
is to lose and at the moment you cannot
shake the feeling that the us are losing
this war um there are a lot of
accusations being leveled that uh the us
the u.s president and indeed nato um and
other
members of the alliance um that we are
we have spent you know trillions of
dollars on this war thousands of lives
have been lost and very little has been
gained so it's really no wonder that joe
biden is uh sliding his approval ratings
are dipping they're of course very high
for the first 100 days and beyond of his
presidency and i i don't think that
they're going to
tick upwards anytime soon
okay annabelle zoe stay where you are uh
if you would uh coming up the financial
times looks at the gender pay gap with a
headline that claims women on boards of
uk blue chip companies are paid 40
less than men discussing that and more
in a couple of minutes
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview annabelle and zoe still with me
um let's have a look at the front page
of the financial times annabelle why
don't you kick things off this is
shocking isn't it some blue chip
companies paying 40 less
to women than to men on the board
well the headline is shocking and
unfortunately it's not the first time
that i've seen a misleading headline
like this in relation to gender pay gaps
the explanation for this gender pay gap
is actually on the cover of the
financial times itself it's that women
hold fewer of the higher paying top jobs
such as chair independent director or
head of committee roles why would you
pay somebody the same or even more if
they are holding a junior role that
might have less responsibilities or be
less demanding in other ways um i have
no qualms with the hampton alexander
review nor the daviess review that came
before that i think that you know higher
female representation uh can be more
role models for young girls and be
positive in other ways but what i'm very
wary of is moving the goal posts so the
davies review set um a targeted twenty
percent on ftse 100 350 companies um the
hampton alexander reviews 33 target so
you can see how the gold posts are
moving my other concern is around unfair
castigation of those companies that
don't achieve uh the representation
female representation on boards um that
has been set and that can later down the
line create commercial damage and as i
said start it's it's not that they are
paying men and women differently to do
the same job it's because they are doing
different roles that may be uh
attractiveness so maybe zoe the problem
is are you itching to say something i
can see but maybe the problem is that
not enough women are being recruited for
those top roles
well i mean obviously when you look at a
pay differential and then you say well
this is because women don't have such
such demanding jobs then you're looking
at a pipeline problem because there's no
inherent reason why men should have all
the high-paying jobs unless women are
being blocked from applying and and
gaining them so i think the notion that
my women are somehow choosing to do less
well-paid work is for the birds
furthermore though i mean there are
problems with these blue chip companies
in the pay of their top ex executives
you know i disagree with the whole with
the entire pay structure in which the
the entire bottom strata of the company
is outsourced
minimum wage labor and the chief exec is
getting 1.5 million in the first place
so there are really really significant
things to tackle um
that is female access through the
pipeline pay differentials within the
organization outsourcing and
then
you know it's really systemic low pay
failure of progression at the bottom and
i think we do ourselves a disservice and
we do you know the corporate world in
general as a service when we fixate on
quest small strata of the workforce and
its inequalities without kind of looking
at what conditions are like across the
piece okay we've only got about a minute
left and i want to get in one more story
at least uh this is a bit worrying
annabelle isn't it the flu jab uh may
not work as well this year because we've
been so preoccupied with covid
yes it's very concerning indeed my
primary worry jonathan is actually that
we are going to see a spike in flu cases
um we're not going to be prepared uh to
deal with that we're going to see
increased pressure on the nhs and the
government is going to be tempted or
pressured into introducing more
restrictions and they won't be
coronavirus restrictions there'll be
restrictions due to the nhs backlog or
due to a bad flu season i think that
that would set very dangerous precedent
freedom must be the default and we
cannot have the government imposing
restrictions on our movements forcing us
to wear face masks or socially distance
because we need to shield the nhs i
think that sets a very dangerous
precedent indeed right okay well flu may
be kept at bay over the next few days at
least front of the daily star
zoe uh heatwave is on the way although
it says temperatures could reach an
incredible 27 degrees celsius i mean
that's just normal august weather isn't
it or what it should be
this is the story i wanted to spend all
half hour on because i'm so excited i
mean when they say heatwave obviously
it's not the heat wave that we've known
by that and by that term in other months
and other years it's it's not been a
great summer and it certainly hasn't
been a great summer when most people
have been kind of have had to stay in
the uk for their holidays yeah but it is
a lovely way to go out right yeah we all
need some sun it's due to a hot air blob
apparently uh annabelle zoe thank you
both very much indeed we'll speak again
in half an hour